ALOK PAREEK: Welcome, everyone.
Today, we're here to
talk about setting
sail in the Google Cloud with
streamlined retail operations.
My name is Alok Pareek, and I'm
one of the founders of Striim,
and I run product engineering.
And also today, I have
with me Neel Chinta.
And as you guys know,
organizations today
can better understand
their customers,
and also optimize
their operations,
by making data-driven decisions.
And a key requirement here,
is to enable real-time data
pipelines in hybrid
cloud environments,
for both operations
and analytics.
So I'm going to
call on Neel today,
to talk about Macy's journey
for platform modernization,
and how they were able to
set sail in the Google Cloud
with Striim as the
integration partner.
So Neil, over to you.
NEEL CHINTA: Thank you, Alok.
Yeah, hi, my name
is Neel Chinta.
I work for Macy's
message technology
in the database group.
So today we're going
to talk about one
of the Macy's use cases, how
to do platform organization,
and then how the Striim helped
us to modernize our platforms.
And one of our key initiative
is common services,
and a bunch of common services
we just initiated, and then
segmentary pricing on catalog.
And I'm going to talk
about each of these topics
in our next slide.
So here, Macy's use
case, so I'm taking it
as an inventory
[INAUDIBLE] use case.
So this is a very
high-level diagram.
So what I'm showing here
is how [INAUDIBLE] data,
so what Striim does
for us, so then how
are we level raising it.
So if we talk on
the main points.
So here our goal is to
streamline orders and inventory
management for
customer experience,
and also profitably, of course.
So that's a main goal
of these use cases,
to allow the cloud
announce new business apps
and achieve the real-time
visibility, sync
to the inventory
data, and also prevent
any out of stock or
inventory surpluses,
especially during peak
holidays, like Black Friday
and Cyber Monday.
So if you see on your right
side, so this is a high level.
So on the left-hand side,
you'll see the unprimed data,
which is coming from mainframe
and some other data sources.
So that data will replicate
using Striim to the Google.
So here we are using a Google
Storage and Cloud pops up.
So what we're using
in the Google,
and then we will explain in
detail in the next slides.
So what are our drivers
and benefits here?
What drives us to do this?
We need a single source of
truth across multiple domains.
So what is single
source of truth?
So because we have many
databases, like any other shop,
we have db2 running on
mainframe and Oracle
running in different
location, and then
each database and each
type has its own data,
and we need a single source.
That's one of the major
drive to go for the Striim.
And also, so the
second one is to reduce
the mainframe, maintenance,
and license cost, of course.
So there's operational
cost of the mainframe.
And speed to market
impacted data,
so residing in multiple
different systems.
So what does that
mean is, we have data
residing in multiple databases.
And then if you need to fast
develop the application,
so you need to reach out to
the different applications,
and then different areas to
develop your application.
Now we are making
everything to single source,
and then everything available
in the Google Cloud.
And also we want to make
sure the different customer
experience across
different systems,
because we don't want a customer
field in the online customer
fields different in the store.
So that's the main
mode of omnichannel.
All the customer face
the same experience.
And finally, but
not last, so this
is the inability to sunset
existing legacy systems.
So some of the legacy systems,
if you need to sunset,
so we need to migrate that data
to some other place like Cloud,
so this Striim is helping us.
So this is our
architectural diagram.
So it's still very high level.
So here I'm going to
take a little longer time
to explain what we
are doing, and what
we can expect from here.
So if you see on the
left side of the diagram,
that is our Macy's on-prem data
centers where the data exists.
So we have inventory data.
It exists in the mainframe db2.
So db2 on mainframe.
So that's the Oracle databases.
So that data is replicating
using Striim to the GCP Cloud.
So that is the Cloud
Spanner and also Pub/Sub.
So what Striim does here,
right, so Striim runs an app
so that will read
the source data.
So Striim app contains multiple
tables, one or many tables,
which contains [INAUDIBLE]
the source data
and [INAUDIBLE] the target.
So you can come
capture and apply,
so you can collect
[INAUDIBLE] and push.
So that's what Striim
is doing right now.
So if you focus on the
middle part of the Striim,
so we are calling as a VM
and suppose VM1 and VM2.
So we are running
two VMs in the GCP.
So we are running two
VMs because search
for high availability purpose.
So if an app runs
these VMs and one VM
goes down for any reason, for
the maintenance of anything,
apps automatically will load
the other VM seamlessly.
And then we don't
see any impact,
there is no business impact.
And so that's the
reason I would recommend
at least two VMs for
the [INAUDIBLE] server
to minimizing outages.
So Striim [INAUDIBLE] is running
in GM, so in the GCP VMs.
And then, that data is pushed to
the Spanner, and also Pub/Sub.
And also, it came to the BQ,
so [INAUDIBLE] Striim is,
so it can apply all three
or all two at the same time.
So you don't need to
depend on each other.
So now how are we doing this?
So Striim saw on on-prem
without running a GoldenGate.
So Striim has the ability to
read GoldenGate trail files,
then convert it in [INAUDIBLE]
use of the target site.
So that's a long thing.
So then, if you
see those options
the online migration phases.
So there we mentioned two steps.
One is initial load, and the
other one with log-based CDC.
What is initial load?
So when I create a new
table at the target
location in the Cloud
Spanner, so the game is empty.
So we did source data.
So it's like a flat file.
So the Striim app can
read the flat file
and then play like
[INAUDIBLE] So
let's say so if I
do at the time T1,
so I took the flat
file from the source.
And then I apply all the
data into the target.
After two hours, that
could count two time given,
plus source's time T2.
So time T2 are both source
and target are in sync.
So but what happens, the
changes that are happening
between time T1 and T2.
Because this is like
a flowing river.
So data flow never stops.
So what we do is so we take
the time T1 minus five minutes.
So to go back to the time,
and then we run in real time
CDC, so using the stream.
So we're going to a
five minutes overlap.
But we don't miss any data.
So that data will apply.
All the duplicate data that
happens at the target site
because that data might exist
because of the five minutes,
and then Scanner will ignore it.
So after catch up the real
time, so they're not at time T3,
both source and target
are near real time.
So that is very critical
for our business.
But whatever happens
changes happening
at the source data business in
the DB2 Mainframe or Oracle.
The applications that are using.
So the customer is accessing
data, using GCP apps,
using Google Apps.
So they should get the real
data and the real time.
So data [INAUDIBLE]
in near real time.
So in our shop, so when we did
this, from source to target
takes 200 to 300 milliseconds.
So when you talk
about this, you need
to talk about that
network speed,
you need a lot of
tuning parameters.
So each shop is different.
But that's what we achieved.
So that's one of the
major requirements for us.
So here I want to talk
about why Cloud Spanner.
Because we have many databases.
And so, we have so many options.
Why Cloud Spanner?
So we need a consistency
of the inventory data
from source and target.
And also, so the accessing
data is supposed to be faster.
So we have so many databases,
everything [INAUDIBLE]
So standard stays on top of it.
So then when you
look at the options,
so Spanner fills
our requirements.
And also, most importantly, as
a DBA, as a database person, I--
one of the requirements
is high availability
and disaster recovery.
So by definition, Spanner
can span multiple regions
so that will satisfy
multi-region.
So that satisfies the
disaster recovery.
In case one region goes
down, other two regions
can automatically take over.
And also high availability.
So if one region goes
down, other region
is always available for us.
But, also transactions can
be accessed from anywhere.
So across the globe.
But for us at Macy's,
we [INAUDIBLE]
across the United States.
Some can access
from Chicago, some
can access from North Carolina,
some can access from Texas.
And if were the third option,
that is a relation system.
So this is also one of the
requirements we're looking for.
So relational, because all
our source databases, all
our transactional
source databases,
are relational systems.
So it's easy to transfer
the applications and systems
from source to target.
So if you have a similar
or same kind of support.
So this is full fledged
relations system, Spanner.
So like I mentioned before,
so this is the real-time data
responses.
And the responses are
faster, and then data sharing
will happen in the Spanner.
So that also meets
our requirement.
Now, so the last point
is need for ability
to scale to meet
spikes in demand.
So this is one of
the key requirements
for the retail industry,
because retail business is not
same like any other
day if you compare it
to Black Friday
and Cyber Monday.
Those peaks are very high.
So Spanner is easily scalable,
horizontally scalable.
And so, during the peak time,
that solves all our capacity
issues, and also user
experience doing holidays time.
Next.
So this is architecture,
why Striim?
So we have many application
tools available.
So it's in the market.
So why Striim?
Right?
So Striim has a highly available
real-time replication system.
So I can send near
real-time replication.
Also, Striim has proven the low
latency end-to-end replication,
so that takes
milliseconds to reach
from source to the target.
Like I mentioned before, that is
very critical for our business.
A need for
enterprise-grade features
like high availability,
recoverability,
ability to handle
volumes and velocity.
So we talked about
high availability,
that is for requirement for
any tool or any process we use.
And also, I believe it will
depend on value and velocity.
So this is, again, a critical
point for the retail industry.
When you see during holidays,
this is a very needed point
because our balance go
up, our speed goes up,
a lot of transaction goes up.
So Striim is supporting that.
And these requirements also lead
to the need for CDC solution.
So we have application,
we have so many ways.
But, Striim, once in the CDC,
so that is a change in data
capture solution, which
is very proven technology,
not as fast, as it won't put
a lot of stress or resource
constraints at the source level.
And on the next one
is need for ability
to write multiple targets.
So this is important,
too, because if you're
publishing your
data with Spanner,
and then same data may need
to consume by the Pub/Sub,
and also BigQuery.
So you don't need to
depending on the data
to come into the Spanner
then right into the Pub/Sub,
from there go to BigQuery.
Now, Striim, one app, can
run into multiple targets.
Sometimes all of
these targets can
use for different use cases.
But we can attribute to
one app from the Striim.
So there's an added advantage.
So the final point is
complement existing investment.
So what does that mean?
That means we already invested
the money on this GoldenGate.
So GoldenGate data is
already extracting the data
and then replicating
to different databases.
So [INAUDIBLE] we are invested
the energy and money on it.
So now Striim has the capability
to read the GoldenGate type
files, which is complement
existing investments.
So what does that mean?
So here at Macy's, so we are
already using an application
to GoldenGate,
[INAUDIBLE] GoldenGate,
which is replicating data
from the source database
to the target database, from
IBM mainframe to Oracle.
So Striim has a capability of
reading GoldenGate type files,
and they transform the
data or replicate that data
into the GCP, Spanner,
Pub/Sub, and BigQuery.
So we just achieved the process.
So without investing
another CDC process,
or EMQ kind of process, so
this complement the existing
investment.
[INAUDIBLE] So that helps us.
So that concludes
my presentation.
And so I know this
is not completed.
This is not complete picture.
You may have some questions.
If you have any
questions, and if you
need to understand more
deep how we did it,
and what we need to get it done.
So I'm happy to answer
those questions.
So thank you, and just
hand it over to Alok.
ALOK PAREEK: Thank you, Neel.
Thanks very much.
And particularly, I wanted to
mention a couple of points.
One was, of course, that during
peak period when you guys had
the 7,500 transactions per
second, the end to end latency
to keep the solution real time,
200, 300 milliseconds as you
pointed out, I think
that was really
good for trying to modernize.
And the other part of course
was leveraging the existing
investment, and I was
the CTO for GoldenGate,
so I'm happy that you were
able to take Striim, which
is sort of a
next-generation platform,
and complement that with
your existing investment.
So with that I'm going to get
into the details of the Striim
back on itself.
As Neel pointed out,
there's multiple solutions
that Striim enables.
At broad, higher level
category, there's
Cloud adoption, hybrid
Cloud data integration,
and in-memory Striim processing.
So let me step into
each one of these.
So Striim is the
next-generation platform.
What you're seeing
here is a layout.
So on the left
side, you have what
I call your on-premise systems.
These could be your current
systems, your legacy systems,
and they could also be your
best-of-breed applications
that are running on
some other Cloud.
And on the right-hand side
are the newer endpoints.
So as you're modernizing
your own business,
as you're introducing
newer systems,
be they be Cloud-based,
relational database
as a service, or most equal
systems, or storage systems,
or analytic systems, oftentimes
you want to bridge this gap.
And one of the key
things is if you
take a look at trying to
keep things consistent
and real time, traditional
technologies don't always
meet up to that goal, and
there's several reasons
I want to share.
OK?
So the way to look at
and interpret this slide
is going from the
left to the right,
you need a next
generation modern platform
that allows you to
deploy these solutions.
And with that, there are
nine different flavors.
I don't have the time to
go into each one today,
but I certainly want to
touch on a few of them which
are relevant to what
Neel talked about.
So the first one
is cloud adoption.
So these have to
do with today you
might be deploying your existing
database systems on-premise
and you want to simply
migrate to the cloud
because you want to take
advantage of, let's say,
a database in a managed
fashion to lower your cost,
to make it a lot
more manageable,
as well as to achieve
the economies of scale
from a compute perspective,
a storage perspective.
So that migration,
how do you do that
without interrupting your
own business operations?
And one of the very
interesting solutions
here is to keep your
current application, which
is running against
your legacy system,
up and running while you set up
a parallel system in the Cloud.
And so long as you're able to
set that up and keep the two
systems synced up
and concurrently
running, then at
some point, you're
able to transition
over your application
onto the target site.
So this is what I mean
by the one-way migration.
More interestingly, in the case
of the use case that we just
heard about, what
they wanted to do
was take a legacy system,
in this case, I mainframe,
and take a lot of that
data and move that
into a modern system
like Cloud Spanner.
So when you do that, then
you need to be able to,
again, replicate that data.
So that's the
replication scenario.
And similarly there's
also requirements
that come up as you're trying
to distribute your data.
So you also saw that there
was in Neel's architecture
slide, that was a
Google Pub/Sub endpoint.
So that's a data
distribution use case.
As we try to liberate
our data, as we
try to modernize
our applications,
different parts
of an organization
have their application
development teams, their data
scientists, their
partners, and they all
want to have access
to this data.
Traditionally this
has been problematic
because it is very expensive
to collect and ingest
the real-time data that's
going against a very
mission-critical system.
And that is one area
where the overall solution
of doing a one-time initial
load followed by a change data
capture allows you
to effectively meet
that requirement.
OK?
So just generalizing
forward, I'm
going to go a
little faster here.
A generalization of the
previous solution category
is the hybrid cloud
data integration.
So this has to do
with the fact that you
may want to do not just
a one-way migration,
but do a kind of a synchronized
migration where you're running,
let's say, system A on-premise,
you're replicating it to system
B, then you do some
testing on system B,
possibly migrate a few users,
do a reverse topology where
the data is coming back
into the legacy system
from the Cloud based
system, and now you're
synchronizing these two,
and ultimately at some point
you're going to pull
the plug on one of them.
Real-time data integration, big
data integration, a lot of you
are concerned with doing
data leak type of projects
where you're trying to take
advantage of Cloud storage
systems.
How do you get data
into those tiers?
So that's the second
category here.
And finally, the third one.
This is truly the gateway
towards digital transformation.
So how do you deploy
next-generation
advanced very thin apps so that
they can be deployed almost
in a micro services fashion?
Just to give you an example, as
you're moving the data, if you
are trying to count
up things to make sure
that operationally
things are adding up,
or if you want to alert on
them if things are not what
you expect.
So these are what I call the
streaming applications that
can be also deployed to
deliver to the business
the ability to monitor the
operations very closely,
as well as if you want to get
any insights into the data
specifically.
For example, let's say if
you're talking about order data.
Am I exceeding the
number of orders
within a given time interval?
And should someone be
alerted in the journey of?
Now, you can always do this
by writing an application
on the target endpoint for
example in Google Spanner.
But for real time
purposes, oftentimes we
have found that people may
want to do that in the pipeline
instead.
OK?
So that's this third piece.
So our focus is really
on customers like Macy's.
And it's typically the global
1,000 types of customers.
Typically, these customers have
a very, very strong requirement
as far as scale is concerned.
So their data volumes
are rather large.
And they may range
anywhere from order
of 10s to 50s of
terabytes to let's
say as low as 50 gigabytes.
It doesn't have to
be, but typically we
see that the stream
solution is being adopted
in these kinds of environments.
And the one fundamental
thing that I really
wanted to call out
was oftentimes,
there's a reluctance
to modernize
because there's an impact
to your actual application.
So let's say your
CRM application,
or your core
banking application,
retail application, inventory
management application.
So how do you then
modernize that system
by making the actual
technology that's
moving the data non-intrusive
to the functioning
of that application?
That's really where we focus on.
OK?
So why do traditional data
integration technologies
fall short here?
And there's a number
of different reasons.
So number one, they
often are batch-oriented
and have a job
mindset, which means
that typically you run
some sort of an ETL job
and then that gets done.
And now you have taken data that
was different from last night,
and now you move that
into the target system.
This can be done nightly.
But that doesn't give
you real-time data.
So that's really one
fundamental challenge there.
Number two is just lack of
support for data streaming.
So if you wanted to give
real-time visibility,
and you're operating off of
a reporting system that's
reflecting data
as of last night,
then there is no
possible way in which
you could do what
Macy's was able to do,
which was to deliver consistency
across a system like Spanner.
Number three,
scalability limits.
So you want to
have a system that
can scale up with your volumes.
So to that end, Striim
is a distributor platform
that can scale horizontally.
Number four, and this is
a very innovative thing
we have done in a traditional
data integration stack
by adding capabilities
like data validation.
It's one thing that you
move a finite amount of data
and you're done, and now
you can do comparisons.
It's another where the
data flow will never stop.
It's going to on an
ongoing basis, keep moving.
And so how do you ensure that
the source and the target
systems are behaving as
you expect them to behave?
So that's this whole
area of data validation
that we have added
into the platform.
And lastly, if you wanted to
incorporate advanced things
like machine learning your
own models into the pipeline,
those are also
interesting things
that customers want to do, and
traditional integration stacks
fail to accommodate
for that flexibility
that the platform desires.
So within Striim,
what we have done
is we made the provisioning,
the designing, the deploying,
the monitoring of these
pipelines very, very simple.
And the way you do that is by
using the flow designer, which
allows you to connect to a
number of source systems,
and you can design
your data pipeline,
and then you can deliver that
data into a target system.
So in this case, what
Neel talked about was
there would be a DB2 or
an Oracle GoldenGate,
or an Oracle, say,
system on the left side.
On the target, you would have
a system like Google Pub/Sub
and Cloud Spanner.
And you could move the data.
And along the way,
the interesting thing
is that you are able to
do SQL-based processing
on that data.
So you can literally
take a look at a record,
and you're able
to filter on that.
You could have a very wide
record format with 400 fields
and you could say, I want
only 80 of these fields.
You could transform that.
So if you had personally
identifiable records,
you could mask
those along the way.
You could do aggregation by
running SQL, doing a group buy,
and condensing the record, and
moving it to a target system.
You could enrich the
data, and you could also
correlate the data.
So these are the capabilities.
I don't have the time
today to go deep dive
into each one of these.
But for those of you who are
interested, please reach out,
and we can certainly help
you with those use cases.
A core differentiator
is the ability
to do change data capture.
So this is something that
I highlighted earlier,
that without causing
disruption to the mission
critical application
that is running,
we want to be able to make sure
that the changes, the inserts,
updates, deletes
that are occurring
in a transactional fashion
on your source system
can be captured and applied
in a transactionally
consistent way onto the target.
So this is the ability
to change data capture,
and Striim supports a number
of different databases,
including your popular
relational databases,
either running on premise
or on in the Cloud.
OK?
So as far as your
overall journey
is concerned in terms
of modernization,
in terms of digital
transformation,
in terms of just
getting to the cloud,
specifically with
Google what we have seen
is in a number of the
endpoints like BigQuery, Cloud
Pub/Sub, Cloud SQL, data prog,
Cloud storage, and Spanner,
Striim is being used to deliver
data into these end points.
And along the way, you could
try to reformat that data,
or deliver it as is
for the consumption,
ultimately, from
these endpoints.
And so, we really simplified
the cloud data movement.
So with that, I'm going to give
you a two-minute demo of what
Neel talked about.
So let me go ahead
and play that.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
So what you're seeing is
the browser-based interface.
And there are two
separate apps here.
Let me jump into app one.
So this is one of the pipelines.
The top part of
this is showing you
that we are doing an initial
load from an Oracle system,
and we are going to
move that into Spanner.
In this case, it's
the line item table.
You can see that there.
And we're going to move
about 100,000 records here.
So let me go ahead
and deploy this app.
OK.
And once I deploy it, there's
a preview capability available,
so you can see the data line.
Let's ensure that the
line item table doesn't
have any records in it.
So let's go ahead and
start the Striim app.
And you can see now that
the data is being moved.
You can see the records.
If I go to the
monitoring page, I
can see that so far
I've moved about 86,000,
and now I'm ingested
about 100,000 records.
And ultimately, there you go.
I have transferred
100,000 records.
So if I come back
and query, you can
see that I have 100,000
records in Spanner now.
OK?
So that was the way in which
you achieve the initial load.
Followed by the
change data capture.
So on the change of
data capture side,
you'll notice it has
a similar pipeline.
And now, in this case, I'm doing
this against the orders table
just for the ease of use.
Once I start this
application, we'll
use a Java application
to go ahead and generate
some workloads.
So let's first make sure that
this table also has no records.
OK.
Let's start the application,
generate some live data
against this table,
and then I'm going
to go ahead and query
the orders table.
You can already see that as soon
as I started sharing the data,
I was able to see that
in the Striim platform.
And then finally, let's
query the Spanner system,
and you are seeing that
there is live records there.
So I just showed you
both the initial load
and the change data capture.
And finally, you can actually
also go to the monitoring page,
and there's all
kinds of gory details
available here as far as
events in, events out,
you can see the 100,000
records, and you
can get a lot of the
cluster-related and
node-related, the
app-related statistics here.
So that was a very quick demo.
So with that, what
I wanted to do
was just quickly ask Neel about
maybe some of the challenges
and the lessons learned as
they delivered the solution
using the Striim platform.
So Neel, if you could maybe
help our audience with that,
that would be terrific.
NEEL CHINTA: Thank you, Alok.
Yes.
I definitely want to share
the lessons learned here,
because this is going
to be any customer may
have these kind of questions
and may see this problem.
So some of the highlights
here on the lessons
learned, so the
importance of testing
and also validating
all the pieces.
What do we get?
What do we see out of the box
of all the tool [INAUDIBLE]
we need to be tested thoroughly,
and make sure what it says
is what you see.
So that a little critical point
of testing is very critical.
Some of the datas because
I need to give an example.
So if you're replicating data
from DB2 Mainframe, Mainframe
DB2 data to the Cloud, DB2
Mainframe most of the systems
runs under character
core [INAUDIBLE] EBCDIC.
So when you go to EBCDIC
to the UTF unicode.
So then, some of the characters
will act differently.
So it's nobody's fault
but that's what it is.
So we need to test
that thoroughly.
So and if you talk second
one, need for additional work
current [INAUDIBLE] Spanner.
So what does that mean is
that right now, so Spanner,
they keep adding more features
and more scanning to Google
is adding.
And as of right
now, what I remember
is the lack of triggers
and there is no change data
capture.
So lack of triggers is so we
need to find a way to do it.
And we may need to
have a other process
to do the work to get work.
But the Spanner
doesn't have a CDC.
What are the changes are you
all it have in the Spanner,
you want to replicate that
data back to somewhere else.
So there is no easy way.
So that's one of the things
we need to keep that in mind.
And if you go to next point,
so, the architecture [INAUDIBLE]
architecture process.
Because this is an
evolving process,
either Striim, or Spanner,
or GCP, any product.
So we're able to adopt and
then evolve based on that.
So [INAUDIBLE] flexible enough
to change those architecture
than what we are
running on-prem.
And the final is
the Google Cloud
provides that flexibility
to grow and quickly
evolve to keep pace
with changing needs.
That is true statement.
Google is working
with us very closely.
They're very helpful.
And so, they did a lot
of improvements for us,
and they're still doing it.
So that flexibility makes
our product success.
So this is not the
lessons learned.
And also, Striim
does very good job
of working with their
vendors, with their customers,
and then make the quick changes.
So that [INAUDIBLE] will help
us the digital transformation
of the Cloud.
So that's all I have for today.
[INAUDIBLE] Alok.
ALOK PAREEK: Great.
Thank you so much, Neel.
And I really appreciate
you taking the time.
And just as far as enjoying
working together as partners,
I think we were able to
work with the product teams
and with Neel's team.
So for example, when
you saw maybe some
of the current shortcomings,
or maybe things
that are on the roadmap
like lack of triggers,
we were able to innovate
there, make sure
that we were able to take
advantage of certain coming
timestamps on the Spanner
table, populate those
so that downstream applications
could take advantage of that,
and then achieve what they
were hoping to achieve.
So we were able to satisfy
that type of a solution.
So with that, please feel
free to reach me directly
if you are interested in the
technical details, as well
as additional demos,
and also labs.
So you can reach me
and look at Striim.
And then, I really enjoyed--
thank you, Neel, again.
And I really enjoyed
presenting to you today.
And thank you very
much for your time.